the satin furnace in Terris parent at
Euro bus diamond
and that is how you try the demon and
that is how it's done he just got a
little scared in the studio here that is
Miranda Otto trapping demons and slaying
as aunt Zelda on Netflix's new hit show
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina and
we have her here in studio Miranda thank
you for joining us hey pleasure to have
you here we got some demons we might
need you to slay out of our lives here
at eat I hope I can remember our wedding
oh yeah if you can't just bring that
spell up cuz it got I got some past I
got some ex-boyfriends we need to say
goodbye
Miranda so everybody's loving this show
it's of course a reboot or reinvention a
darker retelling of this character
Sabrina that we all love and you took on
the character of Zelda which people knew
from you know the show in the 90s but
yeah so different how much say did you
have in crafting who Zelda would be and
what did you want her to be I got a fair
bit of say in some things but I feel
like Roberto who wrote the show I had a
really strong idea of what he wanted and
the writing was really specific which is
what I really kind of hooked into when
when I took the part that's why I wanted
to do it because the writing was so
strong did you in reading it sometimes
even get a little bit like whoa because
the show's dark like oh yeah we're going
here we're doing this yeah no I like the
dark stuff the dark stuffs what got me
in I think it was when in the second
episode spoiler but the killing of Hilda
was the thing was like oh I want to do
that that would be super so much fun and
how have you felt about the fan reaction
because it's a show people can binge and
people are becoming obsessed with them
so quickly the fan reaction has been
amazing actually like I've never been on
Instagram or any of that before but just
to see how many people are watching and
what a buzz there is on social media
about the show it's been and people are
so nice they write such nice things rate
you joined Instagram and I are kind of
sharing some behind the scenes right
yeah okay well thank you she's on
Instagram and she's slaying all the
demons including the social media ones
so we've gotten all of season one but
you barely had a break between filming
this week I had a week a week when we
went straight on to the second season
we're already finished
we're shooting one one seven so seventh
episode of the second season
how do you do that do you call upon your
own magic to say I gotta power through
here and keep filming I mean that's kind
of crazy and is there a way that you
unwind when you're that busy unwind I
don't think I've had much of a chance to
unwind it's just been going going going
but I mean look we have such a great
cast and it's it's a fun set to be on
and there's always sort of something
creative happening so it's it's a fun
place to work
and what wait for it can you taste for
us about season two I think it's I would
say it's even more witchy than season
one okay evil witch business no more
witch bit more witch business I liked as
an isness of which means you have a lot
of spells to memorize for season two no
more in season one in the spells but
there's just more about the witches okay
which we want to see yeah if you had a
couple adjectives to describe season two
other than witchy more like from my
character a little bit more of a
political journey Oh interesting okay
yeah and do we know one will get season
two no they haven't decided yet but some
you know will be finished shooting it by
Christmas so however you said because it
comes out in a hundred and eighty
countries at once they have to do the
dubbing for everywhere and the subtitles
and everything so it takes a little bit
of time now everyone is also hoping for
that Sabrina Riverdale crossover do we
know where that's at can we see you as
part of that no well Roberta always says
never say never so I mean we shoot in
Studios very close to each other
Greendale in Riverdale are very close to
each other but it would be a matter of
finding something that made sense story
wise for both shows right but do you
think it could be found um I I think
Roberto is capable of it I think I'm
sure if he wants to do it he will make
it happen just walk on over so close
also want to be a Halloween episode or
something right Miranda thank you
perfect hitting the nail on the head now
I know your teenage daughter she is she
a fan of both your show in did she watch
there of the original one the one with
she has seen the original one I haven't
but she has caught up with it online and
stuff over the years she's
watch this so has she weighed in on your
version of Zelda what does she think
she's really enjoying it she just
finished it on the weekend she was a
little bit frightened but some things in
it has with her I could watch it with
her but um no she's really enjoying it I
love it I mean we know you from so many
shows I loved you on homeland
I'm have to ask you I do know that
there's a Lord of the Rings series
that's may be in the works yes someone
told me that but I haven't been
contacted about it or anything but yeah
I have heard that they're doing a series
what you do it I'm pretty tied up right
now she's pretty you know alright well I
hope you can make it happen cuz we have
loved you again I mean you have you've
had so many magical experiences you
picked these super-fun boss female roles
[Applause]
you